i i the hardest i ever hit my head this
is gonna be a strange story
so i was in sex ed okay
okay let me tell this story all right so
we were in uh it was our i think
second or third class of sex education
right yeah so
you know how it is teachers want to seem
like how how old are you at this point
like 13
okay so the teacher's like that we want
to seem cool yeah this one
you actually sit on the table so much
though you know you know
i don't know why is it is it a universal
rule where the tables in the science
class
are taller than the ones in the other
classes yeah yeah yeah do you have that
as well yeah because you
you have like stools yeah it's like
stools like large right so it's a pretty
large table and we're sitting on it
and uh so we were watching this you know
and we're all on the tables all sitting
together you know with the boys watching
and the girls obviously yeah so
on this day i decided that i was going
to forgo breakfast i thought yeah
i don't need a breakfast i'm a king i'm
going to go to my sex education mother
and i'm going to watch it and i don't
need no breakfast
so i was feeling a little queasy but i
was like that's okay it's okay
and i'm you're feeling you're feeling
who's watching the video i was playing
quizzes before and then i felt even more
queasy hearing about this stuff okay
yeah because i was 13 they were like
yeah so goo comes out of the woman's
thing and i'm like
right so i'm sitting there and i'm like
all right okay okay and then i'm
suddenly like i just start feeling like
oh whoa
stuff's getting blurry and then i fall
on my friend
next to me right and my friend thinks
classic connor classic
kind of [ __ ] around so it just shunks
me off
and so i go from this like pretty high
tall table like i bet fell on my friend
i just
donk my head on this like pure like
concrete floors yeah
and i wake up and i come too and i just
hear like
screaming and i'm like what the [ __ ] and
i look around and all the kids have like
ran
to the other side of the the uh the room
right
and i'm just waiting here like what the
[ __ ] going on i can't see [ __ ]
like because like my eyes are so blurry
yeah it's so hard
and i'm like oh what's going on
like i'm literally i remember i sit up
and i'm like what's happening
yeah you literally fainted from uh sex
ed
i got so much [ __ ] for it as well
obviously that's such an anime moment
yeah right yeah um and obviously in
school i was like ah connor phoenix you
saw a dick
that's when i started fighting i'm
kidding and so i couldn't see for like
two hours
right vision was blurry and i was like
[ __ ] am i blind
but then luckily it came through and i
think i was just very heavily concussed
by the dick by they were showing
johnny sins his first word oh god
that's like a death sentence in school
man no it was okay
okay i mean so now you know not to skip
breakfast yeah that was my bad because
i i yeah i often felt pretty [ __ ]
sick all the time
uh so yeah that was my dick just didn't
help hearing all this stuff at that age
i was like [ __ ] that sounds disgusting
i hate like slime and goo so much so
hearing it come out of like body parts
makes me feel so gross um
yeah it's the way they phrase it too
right yeah because the only thing i
remember from my sex education thing
because i i think i was like 11 or 12
when we when i do the first sex
efficiently
so already it's like for a lot of kids
right but like the only thing i remember
they taught us which is
the only reason i remember is because
it's so [ __ ] weird to this day yeah
but it was
dead ass the first thing the sex
education teacher said it was like okay
everybody get your index finger
and put it on the inside of your mouth
and feel your cheeks
everyone's like okay and that's like
that's what the inside of a vagina feels
wrong all the girls are like oh and all
the guys are like oh hell yeah
you actually no no no this is in uh
elementary school yeah but like it was
that's
the only thing i remember i i just
certainly remember what it was that like
set me off and it was like i don't know
why the [ __ ] they showed this
yeah but they were they were talking
about i know this is way too much
information so here is a time stamp on
school we skipped talking about this
stuff so go and search it
is going to like leave the room so they
were talking about um
discharge okay girls right yeah yeah and
it wasn't enough to just talk about it
yeah
there was they had this like re
reenactment of this
this girl who goes to the toilet and
they dead ass do a close-up shot of like
white [ __ ] on her pants and i'm like
that's disgusting why would you show
that
we're like 13. that's that's what like
made me feel gross
did you have to watch the obligatory
like woman giving birth yeah
i was gonna i was going to talk about
that because i swear to god whoever was
like and it's
on british tv there as well they showed
births you serious yeah there's a whole
yeah that's all tv shows but
you had like specialist uh videos that
schools like bought to show it's like
[ __ ] awesome
yeah and i mean the person who edited
like our video
they must have known what they were
doing right because they okay so
this guy [ __ ] with us this this this
old british guy was basically describing
the process of a baby coming out of a
vagina right
and so um and so what they used to
describe
what happens the process of this
happening is they take a rubber band
right he takes a rubber band and just
like he just goes
imagine this is the whole vagina right
this is what happened when a baby comes
out and he literally
stretches it like that and then the
class goes
oh and i [ __ ] you know they they then
hard cut
to like a baby that's just like crowning
and just like coming out
and i'm just like think back to that
moment and i'm just like
i think back to the moment i'm just like
the [ __ ] editor knew what he was
doing
there yeah this is like not even like a
cross dissolve
just a straight up hard car he knew
exactly what he was doing
one of those like you know there's like
whooshes in like that baby's head
oh my god they were so disgusting i mean
obviously
i'm glad that i was taught this stuff
but at the same time did they gotta go
in so goddamn hard and that [ __ ]
eases in yeah it's brutal i mean i not
like who no one really enjoyed it no no
no i mean i was like oh this is
interesting everyone's like no what
[ __ ] i feel i feel like it's a thing
that does need to happen though because
yeah obviously i'm glad that i taught it
because i you know you speak to
americans and then you know sometimes
they're like i have
no sex education at all yeah i mean i
i've like sydney
learned her sex education through hentai
and i mean i'm sorry
and it's like what is it like a lot of
the states they just say oh
abstinence wait till marriage that's
legitimately like i think of many of the
states
so i mean i think it depends on the
states yeah there's a man yeah so is it
all mandatory
oh really many states the only education
is abstinence
promote abstinence yes yes so like
christian school
so it's not like i think in england you
have to do it but you have to teach it
by law right yep so every
like like age 13 gets taught like how to
put on a condom how to do all that [ __ ]